[Music]
i think it's really exciting how biology
and creativity have combined
particularly in the area of
health and outcomes and
how do we help people with blindness how
do we help people who are paraplegic
where we can start to read the
electrical activity of their intended
movement and have a robot do that so so
they can gain
you know that that uh activity again and
have that that um power in their lives
again i think that is a classic and
beautiful example of the combination of
biology and creativity making our lives
better every single day butterflies use
something called structural color which
involves bending light to generate color
instead of using a bunch of pigment so
it definitely saves the butterflies a
bunch of energy in making that pigment
but now because of some observant and
innovative scientists it's saving us
energy too it's being used in screens
around the world to make them more
efficient at projecting color which
reduces the carbon footprint as some of
our most common electronics and how
about the creativity of using mrna which
is pretty much just biological text
messages to give our bodies a heads up
that they need to recognize dangerous
viruses it's the technology being used
in some of our our most innovative
vaccines right now
[Music]